this video is made possible by morning
group morning Brewers an email
newsletter sent out every weekday
morning you wake up with the most
relevant curated and informative
business news from Wall Street to
Silicon Valley delivered right to your
inbox morning brew cuts through the
clutter of business news providing a
quick and high-quality delivery mails
that I get every day a genuinely
interesting which is not an easy feat
for me when it comes to business news
but morning brew they absolutely deliver
the best stuff every single day whether
you want to learn about startup news
from Silicon Valley or investment news
from Wall Street morning brew has you
covered and it's quick and easy to read
with a cup of coffee in the morning or
on your commute click the link in the
description below to sign up to morning
brew comm and get the most informative
and witty business newsletter around and
it's free now let's get into the video
john d rockefeller was a businessman who
amassed one of the largest fortunes in
history he controlled a 90% of the oil
in the country and at the time of his
death he was worth between 300 and 400
billion dollars today the name
Rockefeller is synonymous with wealth
for this very reason and his legacy has
lived on long after his death today on
buying graphics we tell the story of how
a seemingly ordinary boy grew up to be
the most powerful man in the United
States
[Music]
john d rockefeller was born on July the
8th 1839 in Richford New York his mother
Eliza Davidson had a total of six
children his father William Avery
rockefeller called himself a traveling
botanic physician this might sounds
impressive but this was actually just a
fancy name for a snake oil salesman his
father earns the nickname big bill for
his larger-than-life personality these
types of salesmen knowingly sold fake
products people promising that their
so-called elixirs could cure practically
anything
they were usually charismatic showman
who truly knew how to get people so
excited about a product that they were
practically begging to give their money
away while big bill was traveling across
the country essentially stealing money
from unsuspecting victims he would spend
some time in each town before catching
the next train he started a double life
with a woman named Nancy Brown and had
children with her despite being so good
at his job big bill always seemed to
struggle with money and there never
seemed to be enough to go around when he
came back to visit Eliza in their six
children john d rockefeller was raised
by his father to never trust anyone big
bill opened his arms to capture John
when he was still just a toddler but
when the boy jumped his father stepped
back and let him fall on the floor in
order to teach him a lesson
bill would also trick John and his
brothers by making promises he never
intended to keep just so he could get
them to do extra chores big bill once
said I cheat my boys every chance I get
I want to make them sharp John
Rockefeller was the oldest son in his
family so he was the man of the house
when his father was gone as a child he
would help his mother raise turkeys in
their backyard so that they could sell
the meat they did on jobs for neighbors
and for the most part they were forced
to fend for themselves without much help
from their father at one point bill
decided to come clean to both of his
wives and revealed that he was splitting
his time between two different
households he suggested that they all
move in together as one big happy family
this was bigamy of course but it was not
illegal in the United States at the time
the moral anti-big in the act was passed
in 1862 after polygamy became more
prevalent among members of the Church of
Jesus Christ of Latter day Saints but
the Rockefellers they weren't part of
the LDS Church now he must have truly
been a smooth talker because he somehow
convinced both Eliezer and Nancy to
agree to a Sister Wives situation the
family they moved to Cleveland Ohio and
they told their neighbors that Nancy
brown was their live-in housekeeper
Rockefeller was disgusted by his
father's behavior and he swore that he
would never grow up to become that kind
of man he decided to save his money and
never waste it on frivolous things he
also became very devoutly religious in
the Baptist Church and held himself to a
high moral standard this difficult
family situation was most likely why he
chose to start working as quickly as
possible so that he could move out and
start an independent life away from his
parents and his father's mistress he
often said that his goal was to make
$100,000 which is the equivalence of
about three million dollars today and
lived to be a hundred years old
Rockefeller attended Cleveland Central
High School but he did not want to wait
until after graduation to become a
businessman so he dropped out of high
school and took just one business and
accounting class at Folsom merchants arc
College this was enough experience the
aramid job as an assistant bookkeeper
for a local merchants called Hewitt and
Tuttle on September the 25th 1855 when
he was only 16 he gains a lot of
valuable experience of this job but the
only trouble was that his bosses only
paid him fifty cents a date even after
inflation that still only $13.30 which
was nowhere near enough to make a
full-time living even though they
weren't paying him much Rockefeller was
always extremely proud of the day that
he got his first job he made September
the 25th into his own holiday called job
day and celebrated the anniversary every
year for the rest of his life
luckily for Rockefeller he had been at
friendly with the customers at Hewitt
and Tuttle this gave him a great
reputation around town
he was always paying post attention to
everything worked and he eventually
learned all of the skills necessary to
start his own business since everyone in
town knew him he managed to get a $4,000
loan which is worth over $100,000 today
this was more than enough money to start
trading in goods like hay meat and grain
his business it managed to earn him four
hundred and fifty thousand dollars in
the very first year now he didn't get to
keep that money for himself of course
because a lot of it had to go back into
repaying the loan and business expenses
but this was a great start to what would
be a long and prosperous business
John said God gave me money and he did
not apologize for it
in 1861 the United States broke out into
civil war and Rockefeller felt very
strongly about being an abolitionist
Rockefellers younger brother Frank
became wounded very early in the war
when John was drafted he actually paid a
professional soldier to go in his place
that way he was able to continue running
his business and contribute to the war
effort at the same time he said I wanted
to go in the army and do my part but it
was simply out of the question
there was no one to take my place we
were a new business and if I had not
stayed it must have stopped believe it
or not this was actually a common
practice back then at least for the men
who could afford it and by staying home
he was also able to profit by selling
supplies for the war effort
[Music]
today the oil industry has concentrated
in the Middle East but back then it was
heavily concentrated in the u.s. in
18-49 a man named Samuel Kerr discovered
crude oil on his property in Titusville
Pennsylvania by the 1850s and 60s word
spread which caused a huge boom known as
the Pennsylvania oil rush men were
moving to Pennsylvania hoping to strike
it rich by setting up oil rigs and
tapping the grounds for their liquid
black gold at that time people needed
oil for their lamps in order to see at
night the only alternative was to
process oil from whale fat that taking
it from the ground was obviously a much
easier process however the crude oil
that's found in the ground does need to
be refined before it can be used by a
consumer crude oil was being transported
by train from Pennsylvania to various
oil refineries around the country john d
rockefeller had the brilliant idea of
taking advantage of this rush by
building an oil refinery in Cleveland
Ohio he was 24 years old at this point
and he had decided that instead of
continuing to be a merchant he should
devote all of his time and energy to
growing his new oil business rockefeller
he was still very frugal so he tried to
save money by cutting out the middleman
whenever possible
instead of buying wooden barrels from a
third party company he bought thousands
of acres of land so that his employees
could cut down trees and make the
barrels themselves in 1870 he met a man
called Henry and Flagler who was
interested in investing in Rockefellers
business together they incorporated at
the standard or company with Flagler's
help rockefeller began to buy up all of
the smaller oil refineries in the
Cleveland area so that he no longer had
any competitors whenever any refinery
refused to sell their company to him
Rockefeller would begin selling his oil
at a loss so that customers would flock
to him instead of the competition this
would simply put the smaller companies
out of business but he didn't stop there
standard all began to spread to other
states and soon enough they were
refining 90% of America's oil
he was now a millionaire at this point
the company was so huge it was
impossible for one man to oversee the
operations of the entire country
therefore he decided to allow the former
heads of the oil companies he purchased
to become his new Board of Trustees this
created a super squad of the smartest
oil experts in the country and he made
himself the head
of this so-called trust this sounds
typical ferb launch companies today who
put a CEO as the figurehead but back
then this kind of Empire it was unheard
of and rockefeller was setting the stage
for other American businesses as a
leading example of how to acquire wealth
and power in the 1800's railroads were
helping to aid America through the
Industrial Revolution for the first time
in history large cargo could be shipped
across the country of record speeds by
the 1860s the two biggest businesses in
the United States were the railroads
and oil so it only made sense that
Rockefeller wanted to be involved in
both of them he was actually plotting to
create a railroad trust and do exactly
what he had done with the oil businesses
he was already cooperating with the
Vanderbilt family and he wasn't going
after the owners of various railroads in
order to purchase their stock and strike
deals with the presidents of each one
Rockefeller needed to be on good terms
with railroads because he needed them to
transport his barrels of oil by train
since he had such a massive quantity of
product he negotiated with the
Pennsylvania Railroad to get a
discounted rate on shipping at first
this was working out really well and the
Pennsylvania Railroad went on a spending
spree to expand the railroad before long
the discount so they gave Rockefeller
was no longer enough to cover their
costs and it would potentially bankrupt
the company so they have to go back on
their promise and raise the price
instead of giving in Rockefeller
responded by laying his own underground
pipelines and he reached out to work
with other railroad companies now the
Pennsylvania Railroad had just lost
their biggest clients and their main
source of income in 1877 the
Pennsylvania Railroad started building
their own oil refinery so that they
could put their trains to good use after
all the oil industry was their
bread-and-butter whether it came from
rockefeller or not since Rockefeller
felt entitled to control all of the oil
he was outraged he stormed in to speak
with the executives of the railroad
saying why it is nothing less than
piracy to make matters worse the
railroad employees began to strike
across the nation because they were not
getting paid this became known as the
great railroad strike of 1877 they
finally buckled under the pressure and
sold their ore
to Rockefeller for 3.4 million dollars
ten years later in the US government
would pass the Interstate Commerce acts
which forced regulations on the prices
charged by railroads this prevented
those companies from gouging the price
for transportation from an outsider's
perspective people did not see a
railroad that broke a contract they saw
Rockefeller as the villain people
believed that he had far too much power
everyone could see the writing on the
wall
if Rockefeller was not stopped he may
take over the railroad industry
completely and after that there would be
no stopping him from taking more and
more until there was nothing left for
anyone else
the general public strongly disagreed
with Rockefellers tactics and they
believes that he was like a shock
gobbling up smaller businesses it had
already happened in the oil industry and
he was making moves in the railroad
industry as well people were terrified
that he would eventually be so rich and
powerful that he might just take over
the world
newspapers they bashed Standard Oil and
political cartoons featured Rockefeller
on a regular basis even President Teddy
Roosevelt was very vocal about being
antitrust and promised Americans that he
was going to do something to stop it the
states of Ohio plan to create a new
antitrust laws specifically to stop
Rockefeller and Standard Oil from having
a monopoly over the entire industry
since it was only a state law at that
point Rockefeller was able to
reincorporate in New Jersey in 1882
before they even had a chance to sue him
he opened his new headquarters on
Broadway in New York City
reincorporating in another state did not
protect him for long though because in
the year 1890 US Congress passed the
Sherman Antitrust Act which made it
illegal in every state two years later
the Supreme Court declared that Standard
Oil was violating this new law so
Rockefeller deal with dissolving his
monopoly well he didn't see just figured
out a legal loophole the Board of
Trustees they divided up Standard Oil
amongst themselves and created smaller
companies so that technically they would
no longer be considered a monopoly in
1899 these new companies were all
brought back under the umbrella of
Standard Oil these are called
subsidiaries which is when a small
company is under the control of a larger
corporation just a few examples of these
smaller companies were BP Exxon
ConocoPhillips and Chevron these
companies all around to this very day at
that time there was a group of writers
and journalists called a muckrakers and
they took it upon themselves to uncover
corruption in American businesses
one such journalist Ida Tarbell wrote a
book in 1904 called up a history of the
Standard Oil Company where she went
through the story of Rockefellers
ruthless rise to power
she wrote Rockefeller and his associates
did not build the Standard Oil Company
in the boardrooms of Wall Street banks
they fought their way to controlled by
rebate and drawback bribe and blackmail
espionage and price cutting by ruthless
efficiency of organization toddle is
remembered
for being one of the most successful
investigative journalists of her time
and many credit her and the other
muckrakers with helping to dismantle the
Rockefeller monopoly but of course
people in the general public they didn't
realize that these new oil companies
were not small business making a
comeback Rockefeller of course was still
pulling the strings and for him rose of
another name was just a sweet even
though there is plenty of information
out there about the financial success of
john d rockefeller
he was a fiercely private person and he
tried his best to keep his family life
out of the newspapers what we do know is
that when he was 25 years old in 1864 he
married a woman named Laura Spellman she
was a devout Christian who worked as a
schoolteacher and they were very much in
love with one another he said of her her
judgment was always better than mine
without her keen advice I would be a
poor man he wrote a beautiful love
letters when he had to travel for
business he once wrote what a blessing
that I have such a good and true wife
how much I would give for wings to reach
you tonight
all of this romance led to the creation
of their children Elizabeth Alice Alta
Edith and John Jr sadly Alice died
during infancy even though he was very
busy he always made time to be with his
family he was a loving father and a
devoted husband who never took them for
granted now all his life Rockefeller had
a very impressive mustache but during
the 1890s he began suffering from a
condition called alopecia he began to
lose all of the hair on his entire body
including his eyebrows at first he tried
to hide it by wearing toupees but as he
grew older he decided to let people see
him in public after had lost all his
hair in the 1990s a biographer named Ron
chernow got permission from the
Rockefeller family to write a biography
he learns by speaking to his children
and grandchildren that Rockefeller never
spoke much about his father and he never
allowed big bill to be a part of their
lives they also never met his
half-sisters and they were never given
any of the fortune because Rockefeller
did not consider them to be a part of
his real family after digging through a
mountain of paperwork Ron chernow
finally found William Avery Rockefellers
grave in a small Cemetery in Freeport
Illinois he was buried under an alias
called dr. William Levengood
it would seem that
even in death john d rockefeller wanted
the memory of his father to be entirely
forgotten in 1897 john d rockefeller
chose to retire from his position at
standard island left the control of the
business to his board of trustees and to
son john d rockefeller jr. in 1911
Standard Oil was sued once again for
violating the antitrust actions they
were forced to split up into dozens of
different corporate entities but he
decided to invest in all of these new
companies and ironically it only made
him more money on the stock market
estimates on rockefeller seniors true
net worth vary anywhere from three
hundred to four hundred billion dollars
and to give that some perspective the
founder of amazon.com Jeff Bezos who's
currently the richest man in the world
today is only worth a hundred billion
dollars only it's probably not a
coincidence that Bezos also practiced
the same exact method that Rockefeller
once did buying our smaller online
bookstores during the expansion of
amazon.com now most people they try to
vilify john d rockefeller but it wasn't
bad he believed in the Christian
tradition of tithing so he had been
giving a portion of his income to
charity since he was 16 years old he
gave 70 million dollars towards the
founding of the University of Chicago
and he also helped create the Spelman
College in Atlanta Georgia which was in
all black women school according to the
New York Times Rockefeller gave away
five hundred and fifty million dollars
in charitable donations to scientific
research education as well as the
Baptist Church Rockefeller became well
known in this later life for the
practice of giving dimes to adults and
nickels to children wherever he went
even gave dimes as a playful gesture to
wealthy men such as tire mogul Harvey
Firestone one of the best examples of
his generosity also doubled as his
legacy in the year 1930 Americans were
suffering after the Great Depression
john d rockefeller was already in his
90s so he decided to use a huge chunk of
his fortune to build the Rockefeller
Center in New York City it was called a
city within a city because it and dining
shopping apartments and even a movie
studio the project created 40 thousand
new jobs during construction and people
were gainfully employed once all of the
businesses inside the center were open
the project was completed in 1933 and
today the rock
has become an iconic part of Manhattan
especially during Christmastime
Bogg refer Ron chernow wrote of
Rockefeller what makes him problematic
and why he continues to inspire
ambivalent reactions is that his good
side was every bit as good as his bad
side was bad seldom as history produced
such a contradictory figure john d
rockefeller died just one year after
completion of his center in 1934 he
often told people that his goal was to
live to be a hundred years old but he
didn't make it past 97 perhaps the best
way to summarize his life was a poem
Rockefeller wrote himself at age 86 I
was early taught to work as well as play
my life has been one long happy holiday
full of work and full of play I dropped
the worry on the way and got was good to
me every day so I really hope you found
that video interesting if you did please
do give us a thumbs up below also don't
forget to check out our sponsor that's
morning brew find them below just click
that link go sign up it's free why not
and as always thank you for watching
you
[Music]